labor day weekend it's not that far away
and the national highway traffic safety
administration right now is getting the
word out about drunk driving it says the
country really is going in the wrong
direction when it comes to deadly
crashes in fact drunk driving deaths
have risen in the last few years
we project that nine thousand five
hundred sixty people died in motor
vehicle traffic crashes in the first
quarter of this year
this is an increase of about seven
percent compared to the first quarter of
last year making it the highest number
of first quarter fatalities since 2002
some sobering statistics today the
administration started a new campaign to
try and crack down on impaired driving
and it runs through september 5th so how
are we doing well as of july nevada's
department of public safety reports 211
traffic deaths across the state again
this is as of july
clark county accounts for 142 of those
deaths 43 pedestrians the main factors
impairment and speeding